I'm just so excited
I know how to make frittata.
So, 12 minutes. Okay.
So, if it were me,
in my kitchen,
this is when you take
the 12 minutes to clean.
Okay.
Cooking tip.
Kitchens
don't clean themselves.
Bummer.
You wanna put it
all in the dishwasher.
-Is this clean stuff?
-I don't know.
Are they the same thing?
-So...
-This isn't messed up.
Crystals.
That's handwash, right?
Yeah.
-You're so responsible.
-Really?
I have to clean as I go.
-Okay, this burns.
-Plus, I don't know where...
I'm learning a lot today.
-Where's the trash?
-Right next to the...
whatever it's called.
Dishwasher.
Oh, yeah,
we should put the timer on.
Oh, yeah.
Feels so grown up.
So responsible.
Like a hot housewife.
Thank you, guys, so much
for three awesome dates.
Ethan,
I love how genuine you are.
And you're so different
from anyone I've ever dated,
which I think is a plus.
However,
Feel we don't have
enough in common
to keep the spark alive.
Tyler.
You are my type to a T,
but maybe a little bit
too much of a ladies man.
Josh,
I love that you're a nerd
and I feel like
you have no hoes back home,
which is really important
to me.
However, I feel like maybe
you might not be ready
for the type of commitment
that I'm ready for.
I wish I could
go on a second date
with all you guys,
but unfortunately,
gonna have to let
one of you go.
And that person is...
Ethan.
Yeah! All right!
I'll see you guys, man.
-Enjoy! Thank you so much.
-Hey, man. Peace.
Thank you.
Well, that was weird.
Does he think he's won?
I was hoping
she would eliminate me.
One of the things
she said to me.
I said, "How'd
your friends describe you?"
She said, "Psychopathic."
I'm like, "Oh!"
In terms of
that being a person
I wanna spend time with,
it's a no-no.
Here we go!
Alert!
Isabella is on her way
to meet you now.
All right, Isabella.
Let's see if you are
who you say you are.
About to find out, Nick,
'cause gliding down
that hallway
like a purple-suited catfish
is Isabella
AKA
her little sister Sophia.
Why am I getting nervous?
Getting a little nervous.
She's a self-confessed
goober,
but there ain't
nothing stupid
about her gameplaying
up in here.
All right, be cool, dude.
Just chill. You got this.
Nick, get ready to meet
your lesbian circle
girlfriend.
Oh, my God!
Feel like I could throw up.
Hi!
Oh, yeah!
-Oh, my God! Hiya!
-How are ya?
I'm good. How're you?
-I'm Nick.
-Oh.
I'm not Isabella.
I'm so sorry.
-Who are ya?
-Isabella's little sister.
-No way!
-My name's Sophia.
Sophia, bring it in.
Well, this has been
an experience.
Didn't break your heart
or anything, right?
-No, we're good.
-Okay. Okay good.
I literally was like,
I would be so upset
if this guy like really,
really got upset.
And I was like,
but he seems so smart.
Like, I was trying so hard
not to, like, cross a line.
The picture was fake
and I am gay.
But other than that,
everything I said
was genuine.
You killed it.
-Good job. Yeah!
-You really believed me?
-I mean, it was--
-I mean, I thought like
there was a chance
everyone could be a catfish,
but I was like,
this seems genuine.
Why not come in as yourself?
My whole life's been like,
your sisters are so pretty.
Your sisters are so pretty.
So, going into this
If I play a beautiful,
blonde straight woman,
I might be able to like
flirt with the guys
and get people
Sophia normally wouldn't.
-That was kind of like...
-It worked out, clearly.
I was like, I'm here, so...
I genuinely adore you.
Like, I literally was like,
I fucking love Nick.
I mean,
I needed you in there.
-Same!
-We were talking strategy...
Same! Like that was,
like, what I needed.
When I saw the fireball,
I couldn't believe
that this could happen
in modern Formula 1 cars.
And a car
shouldn't break in two.
Only when you see the thing
do you believe the danger
that we go into.
The big question was
where's the rest if the car
and where is the driver?
I did think this would be
a very bad outcome.
As I looked to my right,
I could see the driver
through the gap
in the flame.
Not only has he survived
going through a barrier
at 160 miles an hour
within a ball of fire
that the heat
must've been so extreme,
it was a miracle.
Was absolutely a miracle.
Step into my office.
So, the more
I'm thinking about it,
you know my balls
are in a dire situation.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Not seen them,
but I take your word for it.
So, could we have a little
vankle-snakle pact?
I have no idea
what a vankle-shankle is,
but I got a feeling
it ain't cheap.
I need to relieve myself.
Let all the tension out
and we'll deal
with the rule break after.
Oh, no! He isn't, is he?
You two leave,
I'm gonna go in there,
bust one out
'cause I need to.
But let's talk about this.
How much
is it gonna cost us?
This gonna be like a kiss,
like three grand or...
No, no, no.
but this is an investment.
Yeah, this is an investment.
Would you rather spend
three, I dunno,
three, four, five grand
doing it yourself,
knowing then
you're not gonna have urges.
It's a reset.
This'll be
my last rule break,
if you two are calm with it?
-I'm cool with it, bro.
-Keep it on the down low.
-I'm not saying shit.
-Yeah. Yeah.
Sweet.
All right to guard the door?
-Guarding the door.
-We got you bro.
-We got you. We got it.
-You think five minute?
-Less than five minutes?
-One and a half.
One and a half.
And now we're on watch.
I'm working on a show
where a guy has convinced
two other guys to keep watch
while he rubs one out.
My parents
would be so proud.
I don't know how
we ended up with this job.
And poor Lana
gotta be watching this too.
Nathan took a massive dump
in the bathroom,
-gotta wait five minutes.
-Can't go in right now.
How long?
-Like one minute.
-Thirty seconds. Maybe.
-Two minutes.
Two minutes. Two minutes.
I think at a time
we do a little pact.
Like no more spending money.
-Like, on that budget.
-I'm on that, girls.
I'm on that.
No. more. Money.
Repeat after me, Cam:
No. More...
too late.
I think we're being rude...
No, it's okay.
She doesn't care.
-...investigating her home.
-No.
My curiosity is
what shampoo is she using
in her shower.
Because her hair's a mess
and if she's not using
the right product,
maybe that's the problem
with her.
She has a penis pump!
What! She has a penis pump
in her shower.
I just heard "penis".
What is going on up there?
Oh, my God!
What is she doing
with a penis pump?
What the fuck.
Oh, it's wet!
Look,
that's somebody's juice.
Who's penis is Anna pumping
in the shower?
-Throw it outside.
-Why is it wet?
Throw it outside.
That shit's disgusting.
-They think it'd be rude...
-No, it's not rude.
That's disgusting.
What is that thing?
That shit is illegal.
Do it! Do it!
What is that?
So, you're a fan?
Oh, I'm huge fan.
I listen
to the Jonas Brothers
every time
I'm in a supermarket.
I mean,
show some respect, okay?
Nick's a legit actor now.
He's won everything
from a kid's choice award
to a Teen Choice Award.
-Yes! Very good.
-Thank you.
You know, Nick had a hit
called "Jealous".
Though, it would've
been way more believable
if Kevin was singing it.
I am nine months' pregnant
and I'm still working.
We'd planned on having kids
the following year,
but with Covid, you know,
when life gives you lemons.
-How-- Hi.
-How are you?
-Good to see you.
Good to see you.
Oh, my gosh.
This view is amazing!
I love it.
The kitchen is great
for, you know,
someone who wants to cook,
whatever, but...
-No, this is--
-You and me.
Neither of us
have ever cooked.
Neither of us.
But I'm saying for someone
that would like to,
it's an option.
It's beautiful.
Miele appliances, love the--
Oh, stop!
-Just stop.
-It's my purse.
You like it?
I mean, I do,
it's just not a purse.
It's a chair purse.
You don't hold anything,
it's a fashion statement,
you know.
Let me show you the rest.
I'd love to see it,
let's go.